nouvelle édition du journal de l'afrique
bienvenue à vous si vous nous rejoignez
sur france 24 la minus ma accusent les
forces armées maliennes d'exécutions
sommaires lors d'une opération menée en
avril dernier cet état ont mûri dans la
région de mopti à 50 civils ont été tués
toujours selon ce rapport des soldats
étrangers accompagné l'armée malienne
fragile dialogue national inclusif au
tchad plusieurs participants quitté
l'assemblée il conteste la composition
du présidium il est dirigé par galy un
côté gâteau mamadou djigué bay l'a
rencontré à djamena entretien à suivre
dans ce journal
et puis cap sur la côte d'ivoire où la
menace djihadiste est particulièrement
présente au niveau de la frontière avec
le burkina faso nos équipes ont tourné
un long reportage auprès des forces
armées ivoiriennes extraits à suivre
toujours pas de réaction officielle de
la porte de bamako après la publication
d'un rapport de la minus ma la mission
des nations unies au mali accusent les
forces armées maliennes d'exécutions
sommaires 1 50 civils ont été tués en
avril dernier dans la localité dont
borie dans le centre du pays on compte
parmi ses victimes une femme et un
enfant
caroline lamboley
les faits se seraient déroulés ici à
hombori en avril dernier 50 civils ont
été tués selon l'onu l'armée malienne
est pointé du doigt cette localité du
centre du mahdi est située à une
centaine de kilomètres de gossip dans ce
rapport publié mardi la mission de l'onu
au mali et état d'une répression
sanglante des forces maliennes le 19
avril 2000 22 jours de la foire
hebdomadaire dans la localité de hombori
à la suite de l'explosion d'un engin
explosif improvisé au passage de leur
convoi les femmes a accompagné de
personnels militaires étrangers ont
conduit une opération militaires de
ratissage dans la localité au cours de
laquelle au moins 50 civils parmi
lesquels une femme et un enfant ont été
tuées et plus de 500 autres arrêtées
aucun détail sur ce personnel militaire
étranger mais plusieurs sources avaient
affirmé à l afp à l'époque qu'un
ressortissant russe avait été tué dans
cette même explosion le gouvernement
malien a toujours démenti la présence de
mercenaires russes du groupe wagner mais
parle d'instructeurs de l'armée russe et
d'une coopération militaire en scène
d'état à état
à l'époque l'armée malienne dit avoir
tué 18 asseyant et interpeller 611
personnes bamako nature pas réagi suite
aux dernières accusations de l'onu
la réconciliation loin d'être scellé au
tchad le dialogue national inclusif
amorcé et le 20 août ce dernier semble
aujourd'hui fragilisées plusieurs
participants ont quitté l'assemblée ils
rejettent la composition du présidium
c'est cette instance qui dirigera les
travaux et elle est présidée par galli
god des gâteaux il répondait aux
questions notre correspondante jamais
n'a même avoue jean tb
vous avez été désigné président du
présidium du dialogue n'est pas rien que
je vais souffrir il ya une unanimité sur
votre choix cependant la liste qui vous
accompagne et partiellement contesté est
ce que vous entendez sur le présidium
c'est le résultat d'un consensus
largement élaboré sur les forces en
présence dans
le dialogue trouver des compromis sur
les structures qui va animer et gérer le
dialogue était aussi nécessaire c'est
pour ça que l'une des règles principales
c'est le consensus
toujours le coach insiste c'est mieux
que le vote il ya beaucoup d'espoir
quand cette a6 pensez vous que cette
fois ci sera la bonne la bonne occasion
pour régler tous nos problèmes et mettre
le pays sur les rails étaient aussi
organisées dans les plus brefs délais
des élections qu'ils puissent être
solvable quand on se souvient de d'où
nous venons on comprend aussi pourquoi
il ya tant d'espoir ce dialogue notre
passé est marqué par 40 ans de pouvoir
du tout l'espace des libertés publiques
était très restreint rien c'est à la
suite du changement dramatique
du système que l'idée est venue des
militaires qui ont assumé le pouvoir ce
qui est déjà de l'apab des systèmes
militaires un progrès parce que un
militaire ne passent jamais à ne pas
utiliser une arme dire on va dialoguer
c'est quand même un progrès mais non
comment on va dialoguer
et c'est pour ça que toutes ces règles
qui ont été trouvés près dialogue
dialogues tout ça c'est l'expression
d'une volonté de laisser les armes à
côté et de parler franchement entre nous
et donc refonder notre pays c'est aussi
un espoir nouveau
c'est pour ça que la salle tient
beaucoup à ce qu'on laisse de côté les
querelles nos deux petits intérêts et
tout ça et koné à l'essentiel mon rôle
c'est d'arriver à l'essentiel
l'ethiopie ou le tplf le front de
libération du peuple du tigré accusent
le gouvernement de mener je cite une
guerre totale dans la région selon le
mouvement les forces érythréenne
prennent part à ces opérations pour le
gouvernement d'addis abeba à son armée
agit en position défensive
au burkina faso la libération de soie
laine tennyson l' annonce de sa
libération a été faite par l'archevêque
du diocèse de kaya ce mercredi elle est
américaine elle avait été enlevée il ya
cinq mois dans le centre-nord du pays
aucun détail n'a été apportée sur les
circonstances de cette libération âgé de
83 ans est la religieuse était en
service à yalgo depuis octobre 2014
direction maintenant le nord de la côte
d'ivoire au niveau de la frontière avec
le burkina faso la menace djihadiste y
est présente des groupes armés burkinabé
ils sont basés plusieurs attentats non
revendiqués y ont été perpétrés en juin
2020 un poste militaire avait été visée
14 personnes avaient alors été tuées
samuel bernard et anale ferdjani se sont
rendus au cours des derniers mois dans
cette région je vous propose de regarder
ensemble un extrait de leur reportage
le moins de tête a vu
des éléments jusqu'à ce qu'une autre
sinon par les tribulations qui l'on
débatte et ils sont en train de faire là
fruits nous allons voir de quoi il
s'agit nous
progressons vers l'inde à mieux
par précaution les militaires avancent
doucement et en file indienne ce soir
pas d'engin explosif en vue mais à 200
mètres de notre véhicule les démineurs
ont découvert un cratère au sol
les jihadistes n'ont pas eu le temps d'y
poser une mine
c'est se donne le moyen de pouvoir
répondre en embuscade les ponts comme
celui ci sont la cible privilégiée des
groupes armés deux semaines plus tôt
c'est tout près d'ici que cette unité a
essuyé des tirs avant de repousser les
assaillants des escarmouches récurrentes
sur lesquels l'armée communique peu
mieux c'est la zone est la plus risquée
gens comme toi sur cette île d'attac ont
noué les carolos du season jusqu'à faire
de l'emploi en particulier
ses études et ont baissé embuscade dans
tout ce qui est particulier on va lutter
voilà pour cet extrait puis samuel
bernard a était un petit peu plus tôt
sur ce plateau il revenait sur les
circonstances du tournage de ce
reportage est dans l'ensemble le
reportage s'est déroulée sans accroc
mais alors pour se rendre sur place ça a
été très compliqué puisque après le
premier attentat donc de juin 2020 en
fait il était quasiment impossible de se
rendre sur place il y avait le risque
évidemment de d'être sous me d'être la
victime de d'explosifs de d'engin
explosif qui était parfois déposées sur
les pistes qui relie les villages entre
eux il y avait aussi le risque
d'enlèvement alors la côte d'ivoire a
mis en place un corridor sécurisé en
janvier 2022 notamment dans une
opération militaire qui visait à montrer
que l'armée ivoirienne avait repris le
contrôle sur 7 sur cette zone et donc
nous nous sommes rendus sur place à ce
moment là pour rencontrer les
populations nous avons pu rencontrer
donc des populations qui étaient donc
soumis finalement à cette menace pendant
plus d'un an et demi alors dans cette ce
premier reportage nous avons pu voir la
population et l'armée ivoirienne elle ne
répondait pas à nos questions ne voulait
pas qu'on la filme non plus c'est
seulement en avril quelques mois plus
tard que nous avons pu suivre une
patrouille qui donc elle a était donc
chargé de contrôler la zone de
surveiller à la zone qui est donc cette
zone très compliqué qui fait la
frontière avec le burkina faso et puis
il ya la position de la côte d'ivoire
dans la sous région dans cette lutte
contre la menace djihadiste mais comment
se positionne justement la côte d'ivoire
surtout depuis la faire vous savez de
ses 49 soldats détenus au mali depuis
juillet dernier alors c'est un dossier
qui est très compliqué évidemment la
côte d'ivoire essaye de se positionner
comme un leader régional dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme l'an dernier elle a
inauguré une académie internationale de
lutte contre le terrorisme qui avait qui
a toujours et qui accueille aujourd'hui
qui a vocation donc à accueillir et à
former les armes et donc de la sous
région mais alors comme vous l'avez dit
les relations avec les pays voisins ne
sont pas au beau fixe il y a donc des
tensions actuellement avec depuis donc
l'arrestation des 49 soldats donc
ivryens au mali et alors je pense qu'il
ya une véritable inquiétude du côté
notamment de la côte d'ivoire qui
cherche à éviter que les bonnes et la
collaboration entre les deux armées à
nous soit touchée d'ailleurs c'est le le
ministère le ministre de la défense
tenait brahim à ouattara qui est bien
dit on ne peut pas accuser de
mercenaires des soldats d'un pays avec
lequel on a mis en place une mutualité
de lutte contre le terrorisme et il
montre bien l exposé bien la question
quel est l'impact est ce que cela peut
avoir sur la lutte antiterroriste
alors pour le moment évidemment on n'a
pas encore la réponse c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
l'information continue et puis à compter
de la semaine prochaine c'est et meriem
a mal fait plaisir de vous retrouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
france 24 votre regard sur le monde
liberté égalité
actualité